that ohm Alicia's me [ __ ] and how we do
well first you put your hand upon me
okay yes like that
lower lower little lower
I've we a junkie be gay right now
really cuz that scene was pretty funny
but my god it blew my mind when I first
saw it it's easily one of team four
styles most ingenious changes they have
ever made to the series it's no secret
to me that TFS loves Dragon Ball and
therefore they filled their videos with
tons of great stuff but I think a lot of
it goes unappreciated and seeing as DBZ
a wrapped up their third season with a
nice cell shattering heart string
tugging bow I figure now would be the
perfect time to make this video
that's a terrible impression are you
still here but before I get into this
let it be known that I am only
considering elements that would work for
both the abridged and regular versions
characters like mister Popo ghost nappa
and guru while brilliant cannot be
counted this holds true for story beats
like the muffin button and cruel ins tax
evasion because just like my
hypothetical singing career it would
make no sense
[Music]
but then again when has something not
making sentence ever stop them now then
it's time for me to make the donuts now
I know dr. professor scientist King
myself but I'll have you know I own a
fraction of the Dragon Ball manga so I
think I'm pretty much an expert on the
topic I am discussing right now English
words and for my first trick I will
attempt to convince you out there that
don't agree the team for star has some
truly inspired ideas for the Dragon Ball
story that I think made it better don't
at me
first things first let's talk about team
four stars piccolo it's good to have you
back now I'm not now technically it kind
of are shut up now why are you talking
to yourself there aren't words available
in the modern English lexicon capable of
conveying just how utterly genius I
thought this narrative decision was and
still is understand let's break this
mother down great thing number one TFS
managed to retain the characters opposed
male and comi two cages that had
significant amounts of time and effort
put into developing them in doing this
they succeeded in keeping the characters
relevant [ __ ] great let's keep going
great thing number two it gives piccolo
something to God dad do or a unique
concept and someone to talk to at any
time because of this decision
TFS were able to utilize this as a
vehicle of dispensing exposition to the
viewer as well as creating unique
character moments a crush an arc a
barrage Taco Tuesday hell's own grenade
yeah screw you I'm keeping this one now
while funny that clip also serves a
secondary purpose of giving context to
this
[Music]
this is sort of an aside to this whole
conversation but really this decision is
most brilliant attribute can be summed
up in four words no mouth flaps needed
this is the reason why the dialogue
between nail comma and piccolo is so
damn entertaining the writing for it has
significantly more freedom than the vast
majority of interactions have even those
of you out there who don't know how to
edit can appreciate just how simple
creating this scene might be compared to
say a regular dialogue sequence and
that's what makes it so damn brilliant
okay yeah fine crew time might not ever
be a thing but you know what is the
thing these two they're a thing now and
they're budding relationship all the way
to its eventual climate this was handled
so damn well by his own admission Akira
Toriyama does not think he's very good
at writing romantic stories which freed
up a lot of growing room for TFS when
handling this aspect of the cell saga
huh this promotes a lot heavier than I
expected
huh subtle inclusions like this didn't
need to be there but they were put in
anyway because it enriches the
experience by giving us added insight
into the character Krillin and as a
result his relationship with a teen
feels more earned and it all comes to a
head here
when Crillon is faced with a dilemma
press the button or let her go
we all knew where this was going and
this could be a personal preference but
the dialogue and Creon's mind during
this sequence was fantastic
followed quickly after by 18's
rationalizing of the situation as best
she could this relationship felt more
real it felt earned it was more
satisfying to watch as it unfolded
compared with Funimation's version if
you ask me
if you like me are a longtime fan of
Dragonball then you to probably know the
pain of what it's like trying to
describe what is isn't canon to the show
of Dragonball to a new or non Dragon
Ball fan it's a nightmare for both
people hey man could you explain to me
what's Canon and Dragon Ball
oh yeah sure is super easy to check it
okay so accurate Toriyama wrote like 519
chapters of Banga they get turned into
444 episodes of anime with 13 movies and
2 TV specials oh so the Dragon Ball
movies are canon uh no the movies
weren't written by Akira Toriyama and
therefore they are not canon well except
for the last three movies he wrote those
okay so everything in the manga is the
canon source material wrong again ever
since Dragon Ball super started the
Canon sort of screwy the manga and the
anime story are both written by accurate
or Yama they're both kind of the same
but you know totally different and canon
at the same time everything's pretty
much canon after Z huh well except for
the Dragon Ball heroes anime but that's
obvious and don't even get me started
with Broly dude you see what I mean if
TFS makes it then it's part of the Canon
of their show entirely
there's no dissertation that's required
for you to read prior it's simple it's
easy it's [ __ ] better but touching
everyone your planet is a mud hole four
entitled weaklings and you're all
worthless I'm going to claim my
birthright but Dad
okay let's talk about the androids I
gotta be honest with you guys in the
original role of Dragonball I didn't
really care that much for Android 16 17
or 18 you know I thought their designs
look cool other than that they've kinda
boring compared to the other characters
in the story and I know those are all
subjective thoughts which is why I will
try to ignore all of the examples I want
to talk about and instead focus on what
I think are two important additions TFS
made to the androids characters which I
think are objective improvements firstly
let's talk about Android 17 and 18
TFS added a host of additional
background information regarding the two
characters which helped the audience
sympathize with them while trunks and
krillen are looking for cell beneath dr.
Jarosz lab trunks actually stumbles upon
schematics for the androids none of that
information was privy to the viewer in
the original run of the show
additionally boomba reveals yet more
information regarding their backstory in
a later episode these are powerful
inclusions to the story that give
reasoning to why they have acted the way
they have and serve to humanize the two
as more than robotic killing machines
a line that comes up time and time again
with the androids in DBZ a is one where
a character informs them that what they
are doing is a poor decision to which
they respond maybe but it's mine to make
this gives clear insight to the viewer
but they are still bitter about being
made slaves by dr. Jerome and that they
right now proudly live for themselves
now that's good nob but I haven't even
gotten to the incredible changes they
made to the story for Android 16 yet in
the 56th episode of Dragon Ball Z
abridged team four star made the single
largest change they have ever made to a
character in a serious light while Bulma
is repairing Android 16 after his clash
with cell she uncovers a hidden folder
containing an insightful video of
Android 16 before he was an Android now
for those of you out there that didn't
hear near the end of that video
a man off-camera shouts something is
tearing its way through the compound and
behind that again you can hear a kid
Goku charging up his kamehameha
and using that we can infer that this
footage was filmed during the red ribbon
army art of the original Dragon Ball
when goku was making his way through a
red ribbon base and it's during this dr.
gyros son who became Android 16 was
killed that's heavy it gives more
motivation behind dr. Jarosz hatred for
son Goku and builds up 16's relationship
with his father
it's a beautiful addition and one that
only serves to elevate all those
involved I'm honestly shocked more
people don't talk about it all that
aside there are of course huge changes
made to certain characters like yeah
Goro peon Corrin what with them being in
a relationship and all and that while
nonsensical gave the character something
more to do it gave them something more
to say and above all else it gave us the
viewers and you angle for which to look
at the show from at the end of the day
team four star has an enormous advantage
in that they are an independent company
operating as fan writers with over 30
years of hindsight when writing and
preparing these scripts so in many
respects it's not a fair comparison but
with that said I do think they handled
the aforementioned points better than
the original in some respects but hey
maybe you disagree or maybe I missed
your favorite change either way make
sure to let me know how you feel down
below in the comment section
since TFS have now completed the cell
saga I thought it was fitting to cover
the show in some detail but that'll do
for now I'll see you guys in the next
episode thank you so much for watching
also the cans on Kiko ho are way cooler
than the destructor dis contriving
[ __ ] find me
you